les éditions alan sutton proposent
depuis plusieurs années une collection
intitulée mémoires en images l'occasion
de découvrir par des cartes postales
anciennes principalement l'histoire
d'une ville des yvelines ont déjà été
publiés andrésy bougival ou dans
beaucoup d'autres dernière commune en
date celle de plaisir je reçois de des
deux auteurs de cet ouvrage consacré à
plaisir daniel bon dieu bonsoir celle
dont l'auteur de mémoires en images
consacrées à plaisir avec marie souligna
bonsoir bonsoir à tous les deux comment
vous êtes arrivé sur ce projet déjà vous
êtes des plaisirs wade plaisir oise sur
ce je vous connaissez bien cette ville
je suis sûr plaisir depuis
1988 et je fais partie d'une association
ou collectionner les cartes postales
anciennes donc arrivé à un moment on
s'est posé la question de faire profiter
le maximum de gens de cette collection
comme on est arrivé à peu près 450 carte
on en a choisi de s'en voir
quelques-unes effectivement qui défilent
depuis donc marie a fait les textes
oui j'ai fait les textes parce que je
suis historienne de formation et j'ai
pensé que les cartes postales devait
être un peu expliqué à chacun des photos
vous avez trouvé le texte qui
correspondait le contact et essayer de
trouver oui le rhin thècle
pas forcément je dirais c'est un
historique ça peut être un simple
commentaire peut être plus émotionnelle
plus politique et compagne et ses cartes
postales justement on va peut-être voir
quelques unes et vous pourrez nous
commenter nous dire là si je me trompe
pas c'est l'amérique plaisir et bien
chez l'inauguration de la mairie de
plaisir oui en avril 2009 112 parties il
en existe malheureusement que deux oui
mais il doit sûrement en existait
d'autres quelque part mais il faut
mettre la main dessus comme vous êtes
collectionneur vous finirez par les
trous avec nous on voit d'autres images
qui défilent à saint pierre oui c'est
une des cartes les plus courantes de
plaisir d'où viennent toutes ses cartes
postales justement
d'où elles viennent je les ai dit et qui
a réalisé ces clichés qui ont séduit
tant qu en général les cartes postales
et édité par les commerçants donc qu'ils
se faisaient leur publicité donc souvent
c'est le troc et du conte
c'est un support publicitaire en classe
oui michael wilson qui va compléter mais
si oui c'est ça oui vous avez montré
tout à l'heure la photographie de la
ferme d'agriculture en gâtine et c'est
effectivement un cas ni l'alliance de
postale sert de support publicitaire
en quoi la ville de plaisir mérité entre
elles traitement vous disposez de
beaucoup de cartes postales la
collection a permis de mettre en lumière
certaines communes pur plaisir en quoi
plaisir se distingue des autres communes
plusieurs ne se distingue pas des autres
communes elle a une histoire qui lui est
quand même spécifique est donc celle
d'un village agricole qui est devenue
une petit une ville de banlieue mais
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir à quel moment et comment on peut
basculer d'un passé tout à fait agricole
rural à un présent citadins là on
découvre à travers ce livre la période
1900 à 1930 exactement oui à peu près
oui c'est à dire qu'il n'existe pas de
carte postale avant non en france les
cartes postales commence surtout à
partir de 1901 1903 avant c'est très
très rare ce qu'on appelle des
précurseurs on trouve surtout dans les
pays de l'est ou sur l'est de la france
mais les cartes avec des photographies
sont on les trouve à partir de 1900 donc
il ya 200 cartes postales à découvrir
vous en disposez d'un peu plus du double
dans vos
doigts mais non pour faire un livre avec
450 car avec 200 cartes il a fallu
partir des 450 et après enlever les
doublons
on arrive à la fin on a eu du mal à
garder deux sens donc on a mis un peu d'
affiches un peu de publicité parce que
il n'ya pas que des cartes postales à
plaisir en y aussi des vieilles factures
illustrer
les du vieux papier et pour conclure
quel message quel message voulez faire
passer à travers cet ouvrage c'est ce
qui est en train de montrer l'histoire
de cette commune sa richesse ses
particularités
oui c'était l'idée votre travail ce qui
a guidé mon travail c'est surtout de
montrer les efforts qu'ils ont faits et
les gens les habitants de cette commune
au siècle passé et en particulier pour
donner une unité c'est peut-être le seul
moment où le village de plaisir par une
unité est uni autour de son bourg c'est
à dire que les hameaux vivent en
fonction du bourg est aujourd'hui
beaucoup de centres commerciaux sur
cette ville on avait elle n'avait pas du
tout le même image et vous verrez si
vous découvrez cet ouvrage pour se le
procurer on peut contacter bien sûr
l'éditeur il est disponible aussi auprès
des points de vente locaux oui à cultura
normalement au chant grande et les
centres commerciaux voilà sa liste rouge
sur la ville de vétiver et donc et puis
chez les petits libraires locaux bien
sûr on merci à tous les deux venus nous
présenter cet ouvrage mémoires en images
consacrées à la ville de plaisir c'est
la fin de cette édition du 7 8 que vous
pourrez retrouver en ligne d et demain
demain vendredi et puis vendredi soir ce
sera l'édition du week-end des 18 heures
avec catherine mulato excellente soirée
je vous retrouve lundi avec de nouveaux
invités